I know that he would do anything in this
world to make me happy but sometimes I
look at him and say there are more than
6,500 languages spoken on this planet
but in that diversity we have found
there is one language that we can all
understand it's love so we've talked to
nine couples from around the globe who
after decades together can tell us a
thing or two about what it actually is
I've ever said never surround anybody
bla and never me
we've been married for 56 years 52 years
to centimes you say Smith's
30 years well we got together in 1986
that makes it almost 34 years sente oh
no no make a toe egg nog ikuyo we'll be
together for 45 years now we are very
proud of it yeah yeah it's really proud
of all love stories have a beginning so
that's where we'll start
I thought he was cute she was
he was wearing a purple shirt with
suspenders on his tan pants very
fashionable yet Michael that means my
smile let me approach Jacopo Yosa young
who you want
very good Michael I was with my friend
Angie Joaquim and that changed my life
would be $30 and a violin and Turkey -
if they buy her a latte they are doing -
that was like that
sensory motor easily process II
understand changing taxi
yes attached to the novice Emily
digitorum epilepsy motor district Kyoji
is tocqueville at I was trying to
actually match her up with a friend of
mine and he said can I have your phone
number
and I said no I have a boyfriend
Doku afternoon Australia a colossal
ruler available do prefer button roll
and yaw poem to me effectively zahramay
somehow she got me to give her ride home
and for the first time in my life I took
the initiative and called her well
thanks for calling seeing someone is
different from really knowing them love
is more than just a meet-cute when I met
Jamie I had gone to the hospital for
three months I had a dislocated hip and
then he one day comes and she says when
you come out of the hospital we'll get
married and I said Jim what if I won't
be able to walk what are you gonna do
with me
and he and she said I'm not worried
about that she said I will carry you and
how would you say no to a proposal like
that you cannot be selfish when it comes
to loving someone what do you love about
me I love when you sing to me when you
hold me in your arms and you
dance with me I love the way you look in
red I'll tell you that much thank you
and I love your brightness and your
intelligence and your weight she is my
best someone the target tone roasted
babe
we support a new birthday tomorrow
Maggie Geronimo proven cuckoo hello that
you have a sense of humor that is a bit
dry but is there and you often only
reveal that to me I love the fact that
he watches a sad movie he cries upon
gegen animal say mom he Tora optimal
antinea I stopped being around you I
love everything about you
you bring me joy of course after a few
decades it's not all roses
[Music]
yeah my destiny to be slower then really
optical have anyone
what was it give me complete the book I
did you dizzy well that put us on a bus
here are shaky for what I don't do you
follow myself prefer work yeah I do what
try my bus I'd like a vacuum more when
he comes in and he hangs his coats in
the dining room table I should get upset
for the codes there but nobody else is
there
he doesn't like to put things away
yeah well my mom is a mocha angle know
everybody singing tea no snow Aramis
civilians no their most disposes are
over there sir
through all this what we've learned is
love isn't about grand sweeping gestures
it can be but it's also about the small
things that you do to show the other
person that you care
[Music]
love is less a feeling I think then
something you have to do with that
feeling you have to act on it
I still love Valentine's Day I try and
make it special every year there's only
so many times you can cut out little
hearts out of white paper but I do it
every year
[Music]
we dance we're up at 2:00 or 3:00 in the
morning dancing with each other you know
I always support whatever she does I
cook for him the nicest meal what he
likes
now get the coffee bourbon on the day I
knew you really wanted the bird
so I decided we're gonna get her name
below corn a good mechanic oh okay
what a magma a faux pas mo Alima okay I
saw an unbirthday on a limb on Makoni mo
one night
[Music]
we got all dressed up to bring her home
from the hospital that was the first one
[Music]
when I look back so many things have
happened
all of those life experiences we've
traveled those things together say que
realmente tenemos mucho surprises Nessun
Aceveda my services are dogs
[Music]
additionally another deforms mysticisms
in Vig can feel unit conclude Ananas no
somos como alga come with Ozma no
sabemos como Vivian say order return
Gina llamada constant
nivedita Papa canto Lamia is surrendered
opinion navadvip punto Jimmy G for me
and you Luca did your venom a canonical
player by DT me you don't have to be
really adventurous to enjoy each other
just being together is what counts
I'm very very very like thankful and
grateful for everything when you grow
older it's not longer as a VW that's why
you know in a relationship there must be
mutual trust because when you are still
very in love you know you are blinded by
love but after a while you get to see
this person for who he is or who she is
you know it helps to be in love with
your best friend you understand so much
about the other person you know what's
not going to change and you deal with
that you know what you love and you know
what's great and what will remain great
and then the things that maybe not so
great you just understand how to deal
with them better
[Music]
about maturity the Marcel buckets name
my child
sera teachers don't know for sure I'm
not sure Shannon $30 sure what about
understanding understanding water
modulus of Morocco for Vienna and I'm
interested una pequeña boy he would have
to know all about the who no she sat on
La Palma katka home you really have a
friend for life which not everyone does
you know that somebody cares and you
care you become as one there's nothing I
wouldn't do for either and I believe
there's nothing she wouldn't do for me
we've been able to build together a
wonderful family and I love you and I
will love you for always and I won't
tell her I love you too I know honey
I love you too I know okay I love you
too
[Laughter]
[Music]